是这样的哈，
我们的一个姐姐发现了不姐夫她现在是有出，
然后是通过那个在办公的这个电脑上看到这个聊天记录，
聊天记录里边涉及到的一个事情的话，
应该是在今年的年初的时候，
应该是有约过三个人，
然后聊天记录里边儿的话是没有显示是具体是哪一天没有看到他的这个打款证明，
应该是私下结账的，
然后这个月的这个17号有一次的这个消费，
7200的消费，
跟对方约的这个酒店，
然后聊天记录里边儿就是22号的时候也再说和对方这个深入交流了好几次，
他记录里边还有这个对方是个女主播，
我姐夫还给他进行了直播打赏，
帮他去打PP赛来着，
然后我姐的话假要离婚有孩子，
孩子的话应该是上二年级，
就是孩子想要归南方哦，
要财产，
我们现在的话就是不知道要做哪一步，
因为现在还没有撕破脸，
也没有去捅破这个窗户纸，
是这样，
你们现在需要做的是固定证据，
我问一下你姐夫干什么工作的，
在国企，
如果如果能够固定出来证据，
确实有他P的聊天记录，
P的消费记录，
P的开记录，
确实有这些东西在，
最好是你们请的专业的。
人吧，
看能不能调一下那个宾馆开房的监控啊什么的，
有这种影像的视频的这些东西，
在把这些东西全组到一起了之后才好谈，
嗯，
就是现在的话，
我们还是先以收集证据为主，
是吧，
是没错，
他的工作是吃公家饭的，
吃公家饭的工作，
对于这种批的行为，
他一定是有一定的约束和管理机制的，
或许会影响到他的晋升，
或许会响他的评优，
反正就是他的仕途啊，
他一定是有影响的，
那一个人在什么情况下才有可能说我让渡一点我现有的这个利益吧，
是这个人他预期他将来能得到更多的利益的时候，
才会放弃现在现有的让步一部分利益给你的姐姐，
理解这个逻辑啊，
理解啊，
你们现在需要做的第一步就是不要声张，
不要质什么，
当面去质问啊，
不要让他察觉到你们已经知道这个事情啊，
你们需要把这些所有的证据，
就像一个组合拳一样，
要把他们拼凑起来，
拼凑起来足以让他丢工作，
或足以让他呃，
丢掉岗位，
丢掉仕途，
这些证据啊，
整理到这种程度，
然后再跟他谈判，
跟他谈判的时候也要叫什么，
给人家留活路，
给人家留余地，
你不能说。
家里面总共100万财产全都给你姐，
那也不现实，
能谈个70%就是很好的结局了，
好的，
然后我看那个聊天记录里边是说那个对方应该是有聊天的时候有说过他们一起开的店儿，
因为我们不确定这个是不是一起开的，
那个前段时间又问我们这又要钱又要去开店，
就是像哪一些合法的途径能够去查一下他的这个流水，
银行流水啊之类的，
合法的途径只能是打离婚官司的时候能查，
这其他是查不了的。
对孩子如果是给到男方的话，
因为男方他的他家里的这个条件要比我们要好一些，
所以觉得跟男方可能孩子生活条件跟原来是没有太大变化的，
然后如果是说去打这种官司的话，
就是我们主张是要财产，
然后孩子跟男方这种的话，
是在固定好证据以后去跟他谈判，
还是说就是可能前期也没有谈好，
可能男方有有点想撕破脸，
孩子可能男方也不要，
这种情况下，
这种叛逆十疑的概率能高一些，
嗯，
男孩女孩多大，
因为上小学8岁以上，
应该是，
如果爸爸也不想要，
妈妈也不想要，
这个婚不一定离，
不一定离得成，
怎么的辈离对呀，
爸爸。
想要妈妈也不想要，
就把你们忙死啊，
那我知道了，
就是婚前买的房子，
上面是写的男方女方的名字都写的，
但是之后的话，
像那个房产证，
就是后期的那个，
还贷的话，
一直都是男方在还用他的银行还在还，
像这个的话，
呃，
这个房房产的话，
也是属于夫妻共同财产的，
是不是，
然后是结婚之后买的，
嗯，
无论登记在谁的名下，
呃，
在法律上来说，
都会被定性为是夫妻共同的财产，
不管是谁的还房贷都是夫妻二产的，
他是婚前买的房子。
如果是婚前人家买的，
那么婚前付一部分是人家的，
只有在婚后还贷款这一部分跟你姐姐才有关系，
婚后还贷款这一部分，
无论谁在还，
都是两口子的。
啊，
好的，
就是说吃公家饭的这个事情，
一般来说的话，
就是单位对于这个积极行为的话，
是有那个处罚的一些方式，
是不是比较严厉一下，
我们之前没有考虑过这个问题，
一定有，
那好的，
这就是我们如果是说去固定他的这个证据来说的话，
就是因为我们也在说去这个2+1的这个问题，
然后这个我们是说他一定要捉赖床吗？
还是说要怎么一回事，
不是的啊，
如果有付款的记录，
有聊天的记录，
有他们一起看记录，
有他们那个，
呃，
那个去那个酒店的那个监控一起进去啊，
一个小时之后又一起出来，
这都已经能够形成一个很好的证据链吧，
知道了吧。
啊，
好的好的，
那了解了，
我分的止啊，
好，
再见啊，
我跟你们讲，
现在你们可能对吧，
就是因为龙飞姐老干这个工作，
我见到的真的，
我见到这个世界上的恶，
可能见到这个世界上的恶的时候，
我现在都有点麻木了，
真有那种两口子打离婚官司了，
孩子就扔法院了，
两口子都走了就不要了，
你们不信你们自己上网去查一下，
不光两口子不要，
爷爷奶奶也不要，
外公外婆也不要。
那这种情况下，
我要是把关的话，
我跟你讲啊，
真的是很可怜的这个孩子。
这种情况下你你怎么搞，
爸爸妈妈都不要扔法院你怎么搞？
其实我个人觉得啊，
怕他们不离婚，
这个事儿也不对啊，
你们琢磨一下为什么不对，
就他俩都坏成这样了，
他俩都打成这样了，
他俩自己生的孩子都不想要到这种程度了，
你还怕他们不准离婚，
你这不是也害了孩子吗？
真是啊，
这孩子都投胎，
这个事儿真是一个真是一个技术活，
真是一个很那个什么的事儿，
你要投胎到这样的家庭的话。
孩子来这世上一遭，
就是来受苦的了，
就是来受难的了。
嗯，
你就想一下，
爸爸也不要，
妈妈也不要，
把她一个人扔到法院，
对孩子影响多大？
哎呦，
正好我就聊，
跟姐妹们聊一下，
我能当妈妈的人了，
我这辈子千万别干那种蠢事，
妈妈不要你了，
妈妈不理你了啊，
你不要跟着妈妈，
千万别干这种蠢事好不好？
而我也是啊，
时常的提醒我自己，
我绝不开这样的玩笑，
绝不跟孩子用这样的语言去表达，
他不听话了，
他不乖了，
我就不要他了，
怎么怎么样，
我绝不。
啊，
永远不因为你们没当过父母，
难道你们忘记自己曾经当过小孩吗？
反正以后我也不会因为说他学习成绩差就觉得我没有面子了，
你觉得他他对吧？
考试考的不好了，
觉得我被学校老师批评了，
就觉得我没有面子了，
就怎么怎么样，
就去挖苦他了。
我觉得每个人有每个人的慧根，
妈妈学习成绩好不一定孩子一定学习成绩好，
那你看人家那个两口子都是什么清华呀北大呀，
生出来的孩子他照样考不及格嘛，
这不很正常吗？
是不是每个人都有每个人的慧根吧？
如果他他的慧根就只能到那儿，
他就只能考个40分，
只能考个50分，
我也不逼他，
那我就早早的趁着他年轻的时候啊，
18岁19岁的时候，
我就送他去学一门手艺，
他只要能自己养活自己就行，
修车也行。
啊，
开挖掘机也可以，
他自己能养活自己就行。